people in shanghai are losing their
patience with the city's strict
coronavirus lockdown
videos posted on social media show
residents protesting against
restrictions on their freedom
and complaining about poor access to
food and essential services for the
elderly
authorities initially planned for the
lockdown to be lifted on monday but more
than 25 million people have been told to
continue isolating at home until their
neighborhood has been cleared of
positive cases
the government is defending its
heavy-handed approach
the dynamic zerokovic policy does not
seek zero infection it aims to discover
and hold infections to prevent a
large-scale resurgence
this is a scientific approach
and if we can make good use of it we'll
get the maximum benefit with the minimum
cost
but the costs are mounting
dozens of quarantine centers have been
set up to house those who test positive
including the majority who have mild or
nose symptoms
videos circulating online show poor
living conditions inside hastily
constructed facilities
phyllis ju counts herself among the
lucky ones she was able to buy enough
food before the lockdown to sustain her
and her father but says others were
caught off guard
the local government
i think in one of the press conference
she was saying
that
shanghai
will not
lock down
because it's a very important city like
domestically and and internationally so
it will be a huge mess
phyllis drew is a community volunteer
and helps with testing and food
distribution
she says organization varies from area
to area
some neighborhoods are managed well
[Applause]
while in others people are going hungry
and desperation is growing
this video shows people yelling in
frustration from their apartments
authorities are censoring critical or
negative online posts like these
promoting instead images of volunteers
sending much needed supplies to the city
more than two hundred thousand cases of
the ba 0.2 omicron variant have been
recorded in shanghai since last month
but despite rising anger chinese
authorities insist on fighting this new
highly infectious strain with old
methods more quarantine more testing and
more isolation
katrina you al jazeera beijing